SURROUNDING COMMUNITY.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT, THE PRESS
REPORTS THE BORDER PATROL HAS
MADE 32 ARE VESTS AT THE
DEMONSTRATION AT THE BORDER
SEPARATING
SAN DIEGO FROM TIJUANA, MEXICO.
GENTLY OF NEW EVIDENCE THAT THE
LENGTH SOME MIGRANTS WILL GO TO
ENTER THE U.S.
THIS COMES AS THOUSANDS OF OTHER
TRAVELERS ARE POSTPONING OR
ABANDONING THEIR REQUEST.
STEVE HARRIGAN SHOWS US TONIGHT
FROM TIJUANA.
>> THE DESPERATION OF SOME CAN
ONLY BE GUESSED AT, WHAT WILL
DRIVE PARENTS TO DROP SMALL
CHILDREN FROM AN 18-FOOT BORDER
WALL INJURING ONE?
OR, TO PUSH AN 8-MONTH-OLD BABY
THROUGH A HOLE DUG UNDER THE
SAME WALL.
THEY HAVE COME 2,000 MILES NORTH
BY FOOT OR BUS, CARING
EVERYTHING THEY OWN.
STALLED NOW AND TIJUANA SHELTERS
WITH A MONTHS LONG WAIT FOR A
CHANCE AT ASYLUM IN THE U.S.
RECORD NUMBERS HAVE CROSSED
ILLEGALLY, BORDER PATROL SAYS
51,000 WERE ARRESTED IN THE
MONTH OF NOVEMBER ALONE.
AN INCREASE OVER THE SAME PERIOD
LAST YEAR OF 78%.
THOUSANDS DISGUSTED BY THE FILTH
AND THE WAY TO HAVE GIVEN UP AND
GONE BACK HOME.
FOR SOME, HOME IS NO LONGER AN
OPTION.
>> I DO WANT TO GO BACK.
THERE IS TOO MUCH THREAT AND
THEY TRY TO RECRUIT ME IN THE
GANGS.
>> THE FRUSTRATION BOILED OVER
FOR A FEW HOURS TWO WEEKS AGO
WHEN MIGRANTS TRY TO STORM THE
BORDER.
THE TEMPORARY BORDER SHUT DOWN
PROVED SO COSTLY TO BOTH SIDES,
AND YOU CAMP WAS SET UP 11 MILES
FURTHER SOUTH.
CONCRETE HAS REPLACED MOD.
>> THERE IS A BIG NEED FOR
UNDERWEAR BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
WASHING MACHINES HERE.
WE WERE GIVING AWAY UNDERWEAR
AND SOCKS.
>> MANY OF THE MIGRANTS ARE
FINDING A MIDDLE GROUND, STAYING
IN TIJUANA AND TRYING TO MOVE
OUT OF THE SHELTERS.
PATIENCE HAS WORN THIN, THE
VIOLENCE THE LIMITED TO ONE DAY
HAS HER TO LOCAL BUSINESS AND
BEEN A DRAG ON TOURISM.